علماء يعلنون ساعه القيامه اقرب الى
النهايه والناس مفجوعه وبتسال ايش يعني
وايش نسوي
وتفاعلكم يبحث في حقيقه قوات فاجنر
الروسيه
ووحيتها اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
امس طلع اعلان عمل كثير من الجدل فمجموعه
علماء طلعوا واعلنوا تحديث الساعه القيامه
وقالوا انه العالم اقرب للنهايه من اي وقت
مضى وانه البشريه بتبعد ثواني عن منتصف
الليل اللي هو خلاص النهايه والعلماء اللي
بنتكلم عنهم يعني مو اي علماء او اي كلام
نحن بنتكلم عن مجلس العلوم والامن والمجلس
الرعاه في نشره علماء الذره يعني جماعه من
بينهم 11 شخص فائزين بجائزه نوبل
ابتدائي تمام
[موسيقى]
السكن
الا انه غيروا ساعه القيامه لتقترب من
منتصف الليل وانه المسافه صارت ثواني
متقايق وان الحرب الاوكرانيه لها علاقه في
الموضوع واضح انه في كثير ناس زينت ترى
لانه من وقت الاعلان والموضوع متصدر
عمليات البحث عن الموضوع على جوجل زادت
حول العالم والناس بتسال ايش ساعه القيامه
هذه وايش تحديثها الجديد هذا واللي
بيقولوا قربنا من النهايه يعني هو العلم
عارف النهايه متى واحنا قربنا خلاص وايش
علاقه الحرب الروسيه الاخرانيه يعني كلها
اسئله صراحه طلبنا اجاباتها من صديقنا
الدكتور محمد قاسم
اقتربت الساعه الى منتصف الليل ودق ناقوس
الخطر هذه هي الصوره اللي نستلهمها من
ساعه القيامه العلماء حركه ذراعها عشر
ثواني الى الامام ليصبح ما تبقى من الوقت
دقيقه
وعواقب القنابل الذريه تغير المناخ
والاسلحه البيولوجيه الكارثيه هذه الان هي
اقرب مرحله وضعت فيها الساعه الى منتصف
الليل على مر 76 عام من ان تاسست سعد اللي
اسس لها العلماء اللي عملوا على مشروع من
حاتم والقنبله الذريه بعد ان راوا مقدار
الدمار اللي تلحقه على البشريه هدف الساعه
الاساسي اللي من اجلها انشاها العلماء هو
الانذار من القنابل الذريه خصوصا بعد
نكزتي وهيروشيما
نحن نعلم انها تقضي على مدن كامله من كتله
صغيره جدا من الطاقه الذريه اليوم الساعه
تجمع بين مجموعه من المخاطر بالاضافه
للقنابل الذريه مثل تغير المناخ المخاطر
البيولوجيه وحتى التكنولوجيا المزعزعه مثل
نشر المعلومات المظلله سبرانيا او استخدام
التكنولوجيا التجسسيه او حتى استخدام
الذكاء الاصطناعي للحاق الضرب
يعتقد البعض ان الساعه تتنبا بمستقبل
البشريه لكن هذا الشيء بعيد عن الحقيقه
الساعه تعتمد على اعضاء مجلس اداره منهم
عشره حاصلين على جائزه نوبل للبحث في
البيانات والاحصائيات الخاصه بالقنابل
الذريه
ويبحثون ايضا في كميات ثاني اكسيد الكربون
في الاجواء ودرجه حموضه البحار وارتفاع
منسوب المياه وكذلك ينظر الاعضاء في مجه
السياسيين والناشطين في التقليل من
المخاطر الذريه والبيئيه وغيرها
وبناء عليه يختارون حاله الساعه هدف
الساعه ليست تنبا انما ذكر حاله نحن فيها
الان ودعوه عامه الناس والمختصين حتى
يتناقشون في هذا الموضوع حتى نحمي مستقبل
الناس والارض
[موسيقى]
ولكن في الايام الاخيره صار فيه زخم كبير
في الاخبار عنهم وصلنا نسمع باسم المجموعه
بشكل اكبر بكثير وان كان عبر تقارير عنهم
او من خلال اخبار بتقدمهم في او اخبار عن
تقدمهم في اوكرانيا او حتى تصنيف الولايات
المتحده لهم كم مجموعه ارهابيه وكثير من
اللي ما لهم في السياسه والاخبار وكده مو
عارفين مين بقى دول اصلا
هم شركه عسكريه روسيه مستقله ككيان واداره
وانما تابعه لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه وتاسست
عام 2014
برئاسه
من المقربين جدا
وهذه المجموعه بيتم التعاقد معها وبترس
الجنودها الى الدول اللي بتطلب عناصرها
والمعلومات والتقارير بتاكد انهم قاتلوا
في
وافريقيا وحاليا في اوكرانيا وبيعتقد انه
معظم العناصر هم محاربين قدامه وعناصر
سابقه في وحدات النخبه العسكريه من اللي
حصلوا على تدريب جيد وفي كلام انه الان مع
التزايد الحرب واتساع نشاطهم لجا رئيسها
لتجنيد سجناء روس وعناصر مدنيه روسيه
واجنبيه ويعتقد حاليا انه في 20,000 منهم
بيتقاتلوا في اوكرانيوم هم بيدعوا انهم
حتى افضل من كتائب الجيش الروسي وبحققوا
انجازات اكثر ومن اسباب زياده الكلام عنهم
اليومين الماضيين غير التطورات الميدانيه
انه في تقرير
بيتكلم عن اساليب وتكتيك وتفاجنال الوحشيه
في القتال سواء على العدو او حتى على
افراد فمثلا بيقول انه عندهم الانسحاب من
المعركه ممنوع واللي بينسحب يتم اعدامه
فورا هذا غير انه جرحاهم في المعركه مثلا
ما يتم اسعافهم وانما بيكمل لا هم القتال
وهم شايفينهم مرميين عادي كده قدامهم هذا
غير التعذيب واساليب القتل اللي همم
بيمارسوها على اللي بيغلط او بيغرق
قوانينهم التقرير هذا حتى بيقول انه
مجموعه بقنار هي مجموعه لا تقترث اصلا
بموت افرازها واللي عندهم مشكله في هذا
الشيء طيب اوكرانيا موجودين على الخطوط
الاماميه وفيديوهات اون لاين بتظهر القبور
اللي بتنحفر لقتلهم ويقال انه تضاعف سبعه
مرات الشهرين الكلام في هذا التقرير او
غيره من وسائل الاعلام الغربيه مؤخرا عن
المجموعه وحشيتها صراحه كثير جدا لكن هل
هذا الكلام الحقيقي او هل كله صحيح ولا في
جزء من المبالغه من الاعلام الغربي اللي
بيهاجم روسيا ومن مصلحته انه تظهر طبعا
روسيا في اسوا واعنف الصور
خلينا نتعرف اكثر على المجموعه وحقيقتها
من ضيفنا اللي بينضم الينا رياض قهوجي
رئيس مركز الشرق الاوسط والخليج للتحليل
العسكري اهلا فيك معانا يعني القصص اللي
جالسين بنسمعها عن هذه المجموعه الصادمه
جدا فهل فعلا ان هم وحشين الى هذه الدرجه
ولا يجب ان يتفاجيء احد ان هناك مجموعه
قتاليه في حرب همم تقدم على اعماله وحشيه
وبالتالي همم
بلد هي مؤسسه خاصه
عمل المؤسسات الخاصه التي
تقدم خدمات المرتزقه
للجيوش حول العالم
وتساعدها في حروبها في فرض امن في مناطق
معينه الى اخره ليس بالامر جديد
وهناك مجموعات اخرى في الغرب همم
ناصر مرتزقه همم للخدمه حيث يدفع لهم
وبال- ولمبدا المرتزقه هو عمل موجود همم
منذ سنوات وفوق في الشرق وفي الغرب
بزياده الموضوع اكثر يعني الحرب دائما
وحشيه وهذا الشيء اكيد يعني والكلام هذا
كله بس كمان في بروتوكولات للجيوش في
بروتوكولات حتى بين افراد الكتيبه
هنا
هذه المجموعه كونها ليست جزء من القوات
المسلحه الشرعيه للدوله هي لا تخضع
لقوانين
حتى ان اسراها يمكن للجهه التي تاثرهم ان
لا تعاملهم كاسرى حرب لانهم لا يعتبرون
كجزء من قوه الشرعيه لجيش نظامي بل هم
قوات مرتزقه
القوانين الدوليه لا تسري عليهم
حتى الان يعني اوكرانيا
تاثر عناصر الجيش الاوكراني تقوم بمعامله
اسرى على انهم اسرع حرب مثل القوات
المسلحه الروسيه وذلك من اجل ان تبادلهم
وتبادل التي يؤثرونها ايضا يعني ومن هنا
همم فاتن اليوم ما يميزها عن الجيش
النظامي الروسي انها تقدم رواتب كبيره
اضعاف ما يقبضه الضابط والجندي في الجيش
الروسي ومنها تستطيع ان تستاثر بنخبه
المقاتلين الروس من القوات الخاصه لانضم
اليها
وتقوم ايضا
بتجنيد ال همم السجناء اليوم
ويستخدمون
كدروع بشريه يعني سجناء لا يملكون الخبره
العسكريه معظمهم لكره العسكريه وبالتالي
يستخدمون اليوم اا في عمليات كخطوط اماميه
همم
تسهل تقدم قوه النقبه
اللي بينقال عن هذه المجموعه وحتى لما انت
ذكرت بلاك ووتر والاشياء هذه كلها هذه
الاشياء احنا بنشوفها في الافلام الاجنبيه
وبنحس انها مبالغه انه يصير ويعملوا
مجموعه على الجنب ما هي مذكوره في الحكومه
او ما هي في سجلات الحكومه وبنحسنا كده بس
مبالغه من اجل الافلام الاكشن هذه بس فعلا
يعني الموضوع الموجود حول العالم يعني
الحكومات او الاجهزه الحكوميه بتعمل اجهزه
من هذا النوع
طبعا طبعا هذا الدادا القوات او الاجهزه
الاستخبارات وقوات والاجهزه الدوليه من
قبل
المهام السوداء
وهذه تقوم بها جهات تشتغل خارج المؤسسات
الحكوميه
تقوم بمهام خاصه لصالح جهاد في الحكم ااه
تبقى بعيدا عن مسامع واا امراه الناس
والصحافه
الحكومه بتقول احنا مالنا علاقه فيها دولا
مجتمعنا يعني بيسهل انكارههم يعني طيب
العظمى لديها هكذا مجموعات تقدم خدمات لها
على هذه التوضيحات كان معنا
خبير في شؤون الامن والدفاع شكرا لك
حرب على منصات السوشيال ميديا في ليبيا
عنوانها محل العاب
على صفحه المحل مؤخرا لمدير الشركه وهو
بيوضح موظفه والسبب صانعه محتوى
بناء
الفاضله
كويس عنده متابع
مشهوره كويسه
[موسيقى]
القصه المتداوله انه في مشهوره من صانعي
المحتوى اللي بيختص بالطبخ في ليبيا اسمها
منى معتوق نشرت ستوري على احد حساباتها
انه اشترت لعبه لابنتها من محل ليبيا تويز
فرع زناته لكن تم معاملتها بشكل غير جيد
من قبل احد الموظفين اللي ما عرفها ومن
بعدها ما شفنا المحل الا من نزل كده فيديو
او شفنا هذا الفيديو اللي انتم شفتوه
حضرتكم الان بعنوان زياره رئيس مجلس
الاداره والمدير العام واعضاء مجلس
الاداره وفي بيظهر المدير جامعه الموظفين
وبيوضهم بسبب الشكوى ويبدو كانوا فاكرين
في الاداره انه كده هيحلوا الازمه لكن
انهم مشعللوها وزعلو الناس عليهم طبعا من
نعتبروهم يعني انه اللي سووه هذا توبيخ
الموظفين علنا اعتبروها اهانه وغير مقبول
يعني
من بعد رده الفعل السلبيه وضجه هذه طلعت
صانعه المحتوى كتبت على صفحتها ان هي ما
قدمت شكوى ولا كلمت احد ولا شيء وان هي بس
قالت في الاستوري على سناب انه صار معاها
موقف مو حلو معاهم وانه الشركه من نفسها
اتصلت عليها واعتذرت منها وقالت كمان انه
الكلام اللي انتشر على انها راحه المحل
وعرفت عن حالها وما عرفوها وعلى شان كده
اشتكتهم قالت ان هذا الكلام غير صحيح قالت
كمان ان ما تقبل اهانه اي شخص امامها او
طلبت من الشركه انها تبرد ذمتها وتشرح ان
الفيديو ما كان بطلب منها وهي ما لها دخل
وقالت انه الشركه اكلت لها اصلا انه ما
احد انفصل من شغله ومن بعد ما طلع زوجها
كمان في انه اللي صار عيب وانه زوجته
محتواها طبخ وامور يوم ما بتتعامل مع احد
وحتى صورها ما بتنزلها وانه زوجته ما قدمت
شكوى ابدا وهم ما بيقبلوا ينهان اي شخص
ولا يقطعوا برزق احد وطلب من الناس انه
يتوقفوا عن تداول اسم زوجته في اللي صار
فيعني فيلم طويل عريض والسبب مدير حب
يكحلها فراح عمها عموما صاحب الشركه
ومديره طلع بعدين اعتذر من الموظفين
والناس واعتبر اللي صار سوء الذهب
يا ايها الذين امنوا ان جاءكم فاسقا بنبا
فتبين اخوه تلبين اليوم خاطب فيكم كصاحب
شركه او صاحب اعتقد اللي صار لنا اليوم
عصر الميديا معنا شيء كبير وصارت مشكله
كبيره او شيء يعني نعتذر من سوء الفهم
اللي صار للجميع
اعتذر من الجميع هو كان موظفين اللي هم
اخوتي واحبابي واصدقائي واليوم معي فتره
طويله وسنوات طويله يشتغلوا معي سواء كان
همم زباينه واللي فهموا الموضوع غلط يعني
اليوم قلنا فيديو بس نشرح فيه انه زبون
عندنا مهم صار شكليه في الفيديو نقلوه عده
صفحات همم نقل بطريقه مش مضبوطه همم فسبب
ضجه كبيره
صاحب ومدير الشركه في الفيديو كمان شكر
كمان السلطات على التدخلها لحمايه
الموظفين لانه على فكره تدخلت وزاره العمل
والتاهيل وعمل الجوله التفتيش على محلات
في الواقعه واكدت انه تم فتح تحقيق
باليسار وراح يتم اتخاذ الاجراءات
القانونيه اللازمه وف قانون العمل
[موسيقى]
دولتين العلاقات بينهم متوتره وسبب
الاساسيين الكونغوث بدعم متمردين شرق
البلاد
بتنفي هذا الكلام الامم المتحده والغرب
بياكدوا على كلامكم وانه رواندا متورطه
ضفدع متمردين في الكونغو بس ترى هذا كله
عموما يعني تفاصيل هذا مو موضوع انا بس
بعطيكم خلفيه عشان الخبر اللي جاي ففي
مقطع فيديو مبتدا والحول العالم بشكل واسع
وفي المقطع بنشوف طياره حربيه في الجو
فجاه يظهر جنبها والطياره بتكمل طياره
الفجر وهو صاروخ والطياره الحربيه
كوبرا
بينفجر عموما الطيار الحربي نجح يهبط في
الطياره وبصراحه نرفع له القبعه لانه
الطياره صحيح ما اصابها الصاروخ لكن واضح
انه تادب بطريقه او اخرى والنار كانت مولع
فيها الطياره
انزلهم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الكونغو عموما ردت ورفض تماما ان الطياره
كانت في المجال الجويده
[موسيقى]
ان شاء الله في الخميس الونيس اجمل ايام
الاسبوع في امان الله
[موسيقى]